if you were turned off by Demon Souls
and Dark Souls don't let it discourage
you from playing blood-borne my own
relationship with the souls games is
fractured because I found them far too
hard I love the idea of video games not
holding your hand of taking away all
directional markers and quest logs and
forcing you to explore and learn your
way through the world by trial and error
developer from software trusts its
players to put the time in but
unfortunately for me I felt that souls
learning curve was a little too steep
however I feel that blood-borne is the
more accessible successor to the souls
games
make no mistake blood-borne pulls no
punches right from the start you're
thrown into the world of yharnam with
much fanfare and none of it positive the
world and its inhabitants are all out to
get you and the game immediately opens
on your first steps in preparing for
combat against them the most obvious
element that makes blood-borne dare we
say easier than its predecessors is that
if you die the game doesn't knock off a
fraction of the total health available
to you in Dark Souls 2 death meant you
lost 10% of your health bar until you
used a special item to regain it in
blood-borne you'll keep your health
points after death this is especially
helpful as enemies progressively require
more than a few blows and quite a bit of
stamina to kill I know I'm grateful to
keep my hard-earned health points when I
have to repeatedly face down the same
boss conveniently all upgrades and items
you need can be purchased in your hub
world hunter stream hunters dream is an
accurate name for it as it's seriously a
dream both in terms of what it offers
you and how pretty it looks the hub
world is more centralized in previous
souls games so you don't have to run all
over yarn I'm looking for the nitty
gritty that you need blood warns level
design encourages you to explore between
it's lengthy checkpoints by removing any
waypoints and making Direction hints
subtle by not giving a means to track
where you are and where you need to go
other than your own memory blood-borne
tricks you into moving forward an
environment design relies less on gotcha
moments to help you understand what
you're up against then previous souls
games there are no moments set up to
kill you just to kill you no cheap traps
there's less reliance on throwing unseen
pitfalls in your way instead they are
obstacles for you to observe learn from
and surmount blood-borne setup isn't
cruel it's a never-ending challenge that
feels
even handed bloodborne also makes sure
you always have the tools you need to
survive whether or not you use them to
your advantage is entirely up to you for
example you always have access to health
restoring blood vials both in hunters
dream and as a common enemy drop both
blood vials and Quicksilver bullets are
dropped by many enemies you kill
ensuring that you'll never be without in
the souls games refilling Estus flasks
required you to either die or return to
the hub world enemies didn't drop health
items but in blood-borne if you run out
of blood or bullets chances are a nearby
enemy will also have something you need
this rewards pushing forward / playing
it safe all of this boils down to a
world that might not be fun all the time
but it's definitely satisfying to master
blood-borne is a smidge easier than
other souls games and that it keeps your
health steady and your inventory
well-stocked but that doesn't mean the
enemies you'll face are less difficult
you'll fight to earn your status as a
master hunter make no mistake but
blood-borne is at its heart a more
accessible introduction to the souls
games for newcomers